there's a well-known saying that those
who don't remember the past are
condemned to repeat it
that's part of the message in the new
book by historian and author David
McCullough he's earned two Pulitzer
Prizes two National Book Awards and the
Presidential Medal of Freedom that is
the nation's highest civilian honor his
book is the American spirit who we are
and what we stand for and is a
collection of his speeches over the past
28 years the book is published by Simon
& Schuster a division of CBS David good
morning good morning so wonderful to
have you here as I'm such a fan of yours
including the book about Truman you've
been giving speeches for 50 years okay
why did you decide to put them together
in this book because I feel that we were
going through a very difficult and
unprecedented experience of the country
right now and that we need to be
reminded and with respect of who we are
and what we stand for and what our
predecessors went through to achieve
what we have to often take for granted
and set standards for us to live up to
reminded of what well that we believed
in honesty we believed in the hard work
and loyalty we believed in love of
country beyond just a lot of flag waving
and mouthing off of cliches that we
believed in improvement and
accomplishment and that we believe that
we have a way of life like none else in
the world and we not only want to
maintain it but we want to improve it
your words that there's always going to
be problems in the country it's no
issues it's never been easy but you told
the graduates at Ohio in 2004 the
committee will always believe this
country's going to the dogs but 90% of
the people in this country are good
law-abiding citizens and we forget that
exactly that absolutely we need to be
reminded of it I'm still out in the
country talking to students talking to
people in lecture halls and and I like
to stress that if you know your history
if you know your country's story the
human side of the story you'll never
take it for granted
and you'll always be grateful to those
who went before us who not only had the
faith that they did but who did the work
that needed to be done and risked their
lives very often
we've always you've always stressed the
importance of a liberal arts education
and an education in history world
history and US history indeed absolutely
I think history the English language and
history are to me them two most
important of all subjects for everybody
to know kids don't know their history
and people in positions of leadership
particularly they have to know cause and
effect they have to know not only what
previous presidents let's say did but
what they didn't do which was often as
important the decisions they didn't make
and and their use of the English
language the people who have been most
inspiring for us we all know who they
were have been people who used note knew
how to use words Abraham Lincoln John
Kennedy do you know it's been 56 years
since the president United States asked
us to do something for our country you
know yeah and a lot of us in that day
that's when I was first trying to figure
out what I wanted to do in my life we
took it we took it to heart and we went
to do something for our country you know
and we've not we've not been the same
ever since the break variety of fields
David I thought about that because you
start with Simon Willard's clock the the
speech that you gave to the joint
address of Congress and you just talk
about these great Americans that served
in Congress you know when Americans hate
Congress have a nine percent approval
rating you remind us all that it's
Congress that passed the Homestead Act
ended slavery the GI Bill the Marshall
Plan I mean on and on and on these great
things that Congress has done for our
country and the great people that served
know you said it's not always been an
unbroken parade of clowns very
interesting way of thank you sometimes
we have a run on them
but you're still an optimist right here
why the glass is half-full
ya know because so much of what is it is
actually happening isn't reported
because it's good news yeah yeah but
this is my favorite line in your book
you told graduates in 1994 if you're
happy you think better yeah that's true
it works happy you think that I see
pages in your book by the way the
dedication page to here you know I
counted 19 grandchildren yes
congratulations and it's dedicated to
them because my hope is that the values
that are expressed in the actions and
the words and an accomplishment of our
predecessors will go on into their
generation to give it McCulloch thank
you so much for all of this so much